SPEAKER 1: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today what I want
to do within the lexicon
is tell you about nature's
most spectacularly beautiful
cofactors.
And these are formed from
vitamin B-12, which you
find in your vitamin bottle.
OK.
So what is the structure
of vitamin B-12, and why
do I say they are
spectacularly beautiful?
So it's very hard
to see, but if you
look at the structure
of this, where
have you seen a molecule
this complicated
with five membered
rings, each of which
has a nitrogen in this?
You've seen this when
you studied hemoglobin,
and you think about heme
and proto protoporphyrin IX.
If you look at the
biosynthetic pathway of heme,
a branchpoint of that pathway
is to make this ring, which
is found in adenosylcobalamin
and methylcobalamin, which
is what we're going to
be focusing on today.
And this ring is
called the corrin ring.
So what I want to
do is introduce
you a little bit
to this corrin ring
and what's unusual about it
compared to protoporphyrin IX
that you've seen before.
So the vitamin, as in the case
of all vitamins that we've
talked about over the
course of the semester,
is not the actual
cofactor used in
the enzymatic transformation.
The vitamin, which in this case
would have this group replaced
with cyanide, is vitamin B-12.
The actual cofactors
that bind to the enzyme
have that cyanide replaced
with either a methyl
group-- and that's
called methylcobalamin--
or they have it replaced
with 5-prime-deoxyadenosine,
and that's called
adenosylcobalamin.
And so the rest of the
molecule is exactly the same.
The only thing that's
distinct is the axial ligands.
So you remember from your
transition metal chemistry
you had when you were
freshman that here you
have a cobalt III, and it's
coordinated to four nitrogens.
OK?
So this would be the
equatorial plane,
and we're going to draw it
like this, subsequently,
because you can see how
complicated this molecule is.
And the middle sits
right in this plane,
but you can see
that you don't have
complete saturation of
these pyrrole- type rings,
so there's some
pucker in contrast
with hemes which are very flat.
And then these are called
equatorial ligands,
and then you have axial ligands.
And so there are
a number of things
that again I wanted to point
out that are unusual about B-12.
One is the fact that the
corrin ring again is much more
reduced than a pyrrole ring.
And so it's puckered.
And if you look at the visible
spectrum, or you use your eye
and use your eyeball method,
you see that cyanocobalamin
is bright purple.
If you replace this R
group with a methyl group,
this color turns out to
be sort of yellow-orange.
And if you replace this
with 5-prime-deoxyadenosine,
it turns out to be pink.
So that's why I say that this
is nature's most spectacularly
beautiful cofactor.
So the other thing is you
have two axial ligands.
I just introduced you to
these guys on the top face.
But what you also see
on the bottom face--
the bottom axial ligand--
is this unusual structure,
which is called
dimethylbenzimidazole.
And it's attached to a
ribose, but the unusual thing
is in most nucleosides that
you've encountered like ATP,
this configuration is
in the beta position--
it's on the top
face of the sugar--
and here it's in
the alpha position.
So that's distinct.
And the other thing
that's distinct
is the decorations around
the side chain compared
to what you see in porphyrins.
So this is the cofactor we're
going to be talking about,
and one of the questions
that you're interested in
is where do we find thes
cofactors in metabolism.
In a mammalian metabolism, the
appearance of these cofactors
is quite limited.
So the only place you see it in
metabolism in mammalian systems
is you see
methylcobalamin-- OK, where
this is a methyl group-- in
formation of the amino acid
methionine.
And so the methyl
group from methionine--
I'll show you briefly
at the very end
of this little presentation--
comes from this methyl group.
You use adenosylcobalamin in
odd chain fatty acid metabolism.
So you have fatty acids that are
either an even or an odd chain.
When you break the
odd chain ones down,
you get proprionyl CoA.
The proprionyl CoA,
through a series of steps,
is converted into
malonyl CoA, which
then gets converted
to succinyl COA,
which feeds into the TCA cycle.
And in that pathway, you
use an enzyme-- a mutase--
that uses a adenosylcobalamin.
We'll talk briefly
about the chemistry
of a adenosylcobalamin;
also methylcobalamin.
OK.
So there were a
few things that I
wanted to say about-- some
generalizations that I wanted
to make about these cofactors.
And at the first one is
that again, the corrin ring
is much more reduced
than the pyrrole ring
that you see in protoporphyrin
IX, which you've
seen in hemoglobin before.
The second thing
is that you have
this unusual
dimethylbenzimidazole axial
ligand, which you see nowhere
else in cofactor chemistry.
It's only found in this
particular cofactor.
The second thing, which I
think is the most amazing,
is that what you see
if you look back here
is that you have-- if
this is a methyl group,
or this is this
5-prime-deoxyadenosine--
you have a carbon cobalt bond.
Well, this was
discovered in the 1950s,
and the first structure
was solved of this molecule
by Dorothy Crowfoot
Hodgkin in 1964,
and she won the Nobel
Prize for this work.
No chemist had ever seen a
carbon cobalt blonde bond,
and thought in fact biochemists
were crazy that they even
proposed such a structure.
So this structure--
and we'll see
that this is where all
the chemistry happens--
is completely unique.
And people spent 25
years figuring out
how this cofactor
actually worked
to do the transformations that
I'll very briefly introduce you
to.
So this is the first
example of a carbon cobalt--
and will see that cobalt is
in the plus 3 oxidation state
bond-- so it's the first
organo-metallic cofactor.
And what people also found
by studying this molecule
is that the cobalt can actually
exist in three oxidation
states.
It can exist in the
cobalt I state, where
in the d z squared orbital--
if you don't remember what a d
z squared orbital is, you
need to go back and look
at your freshman chemistry--
you have two electrons.
And it turns out that cobalt
I is a super nucleophile.
And we'll see that that plays
a key role in the chemistry.
And so again, this
is the cobalt. The d.
We're only looking at one of
the orbitals of the cobalt.
On the other hand-- and
this is found in methyl--
this is going to be
used in methylcobalamin.
So when you have a methyl
as the axial ligand,
you're going to use cobalt in
this oxidation state, which
is the plus one state.
For almost all other
B-12 dependent reactions,
you have cobalt II, which
has-- you've lost an electron,
so you have only one
electron by itself.
And its d z squared orbital.
And this really
dictates the chemistry.
And so this is found in
adenosylcobalamin chemistry.
And then in the resting the
state you have cobalt III.
And cobalt III has none
of the electrons in the d
z squared orbital.
And this is basically the
resting state-- its most stable
state-- where you
find this cofactor.
So in cyanocobalamin,
which is vitamin B-12,
the cobalt is in the
plus 3 oxidation state.
OK.
So we're going to see
very briefly-- we're
not spending much time on
this-- is the cobalt I state.
It's a super good nucleophile.
It affects the chemistry
of the cobalt II state.
It has one unpaired electron.
You haven't been
introduced to chemistry
with one unpaired
electron, which
is radical chemistry-- that
most people don't spend
a lot of time talking about
adenosylcobalamin because it's
radicals, and they don't
learn much about radicals
in introductory
organic chemistry.
But I'll show you briefly
how the enzymes work
that use this cobalt II state.
The other thing I wanted
to mention was the colors.
And so if you want to understand
how these cofactors work,
the different
number of electrons
govern what colors
you can end up seeing.
And again I always use
this is as an example
on MIT'S campus in the spring.
Cobalt II has spectacular orange
color like the orange azaleas,
and cobalt III is
like the pink azaleas.
And so they're really
dramatically different.
And this is why I say
this is nature's most
beautiful cofactor.
OK.
So what I want to do now is
briefly talk about mechanism.
And I'm going to mostly
talk about mechanism
of the cobalt II state, and
how adenosylcobalamin works,
since that's the one
that's most complicated.
So what I'm drawing
here is if we
look at the structure
of adenosylcobalamin,
you see you have a cobalt
with four nitrogen.
These are the four
nitrogens and these
are the two axial ligands.
So this is the
abbreviation I'm going
to be using in all the
subsequent chemical
descriptions of what
I'm talking about, OK?
So I'm not going to draw this
structure out over and over
again.
OK.
So here's our adenosylcobalamin
that we just talked about.
And there's DMB.
It's a dimethylbenzimidazole
axial ligand,
and then you have the
5-prime-deoxyadenosine
in the top face, which is
where all the chemistry is
going to happen.
So the business
end of the molecule
is going to be this
part of the molecule.
And the key to everything
is this carbon cobalt bond.
Now, what's unusual about
a carbon cobalt bond?
It's very weak.
If you go to 40 degrees,
the bond breaks.
Most things-- you can go
to hundreds of degrees,
and the bond is stable.
So it's thermally labile.
And then the other thing that's
unique about this cofactor
is that it's light sensitive.
So if you put adenosylcobalamin
out on the bench top
here, within two
minutes the whole thing
would be destroyed because you
would break this carbon cobalt
bond.
OK?
And that's the key
to the chemistry
of how this cofactor works.
OK?
So I'm going to give
you a generic mechanism,
and then I'm going to
focus on the mechanism
of methylmalonyl-CoA
mutase, which
you find in human metabolism.
Before I get started,
let me just show you
what the reaction is and
show you why it's unusual,
and then we'll go back
to the actual mechanism.
OK.
So what does
methylmalonyl-CoA mutase do?
Again it plays a central
role in odd chain fatty acid
metabolism.
OK, so this is CoA.
You need to go back and
look at your lexicon
if you can't remember
the structure CoA.
But just remember
it's a thioester.
That's all you need to know.
OK.
So this is the
substrate, and this
is called methylmalonyl-CoA.
OK.
So adenosylcobalamin
catalyzes rearrangements.
And this reaction has
fascinated chemists for 30 years
because there was no
chemical precedent--
just like there was no chemical
precedent for carbon cobalt
bonds.
When biochemists
discovered this,
there was no precedent for the
reaction I'm going to show you.
So what is the reaction?
It's a rearrangement.
And it's a rearrangement
because this hydrogen
moves from this
carbon to this carbon.
And this whole group--
this thioester--
moves from this
carbon to this carbon.
So that's the actual reaction.
It's reversible.
And so what you do is you
generate succinyl CoA.
OK so this hydrogen
is moved over here.
And this is succinyl CoA.
And we haven't
talked about it yet,
but succinyl CoA
plays a central role
in metabolism in the TCA cycle.
OK.
So the question that
we want to focus on now
is how do you catalyze
this weird rearrangement.
What is this cofactor?
This big, huge molecule with
this weak carbon cobalt bond.
What does it do?
OK.
So I'm going to come
back to this in a minute,
but just let me show
you what it does.
OK.
So this is a generic
mechanism, because while I
said there's only one
enzyme in humans that
uses adenosylcobalamin,
if you move into fungi,
or you move into
archaea, or bacteria,
you find there are many B-12
dependent reactions that
also do rearrangements,
but different kinds
of rearrangements.
OK.
So what's the generic mechanism?
So the generic mechanism
is the following.
So here we have our
adenosylcobalamin.
Here's our substrate.
OK.
And the idea is we need to move
the hydrogen from here to here.
OK?
Does it just jump through space?
And the answer is no.
The cofactor
adenosylcobalamin is
going to remove the
hydrogen, and then it's
going to transfer it.
You're going to generate
a reactive speciea,
and then it's going to transfer
it back to form a new product.
So the cofactor-- and this
took people a long time
to figure out because there
was no chemical precedent
for this-- is mediating
the hydrogen transfer.
So that's what I'm going to show
you-- how that actually works.
So here what happens
is the whole key
to the chemistry of
adenosylcobalamin--
which again, most of you
haven't seen something like this
before because you're not
exposed to radical chemistry--
is that you have homolysis
of the carbon cobalt bond.
So what does that mean?
It means one electron
goes to the axial ligand,
and one electron
goes to the cobalt.
So the cobalt III is reduced
from cobalt III to cobalt II,
and what you're left with
is this radical species
of 5-prime-deoxyadenosyl
radical.
OK.
So this is the reactive species.
Because what you're doing
in these transformations is
pulling off an amazingly
non acidic hydrogen.
And normal amino acid side
chains cannot do that kind
of chemistry.
You have to go to these
reactive radical species
to be able to do
this tough chemistry.
So here we generated
a radical species.
It is sitting right
next to the substrate
in the active site
of the enzyme.
And so what does it do?
It removes a hydrogen atom--
a hydrogen with one electron.
OK?
And so again, this is
free radical chemistry
that most of you don't
think about that much.
But what you do is the
hydrogen from the substrate
is now transferred
to this axial ligand
and that stays stuck
in the active site.
So we've seen this
guy move over here.
And now what you've
done is transferred
one radical from the cofactor
into a second radical--
the substrate.
OK.
So that's the key.
Now it's carrying this
hydrogen, and eventually it
wants to put the hydrogen
back on to form the product.
OK?
That's part of the
rearrangement reaction.
So what happens now is--
and this looks like magic.
I'm just showing that a
substrate radical goes
to product radical,
and I will show you
how this works in the case
of methylmalonyl-CoA mutase
in a minute, OK?
So there's some kind
of rearrangement.
Remember we had two things
rearranging the hydrogen,
but we also had a second--
a thioester rearranging.
So we have a
rearrangement reaction,
and this is reversible
in the reaction I'm going
to be talking about today.
And so this is the same is this.
Structurally these are the same.
I've just written
the methyl group.
And so we have a
substrate radical
converting into a
product radical.
OK?
And now what we want to do
is generate the product.
And so the hydrogen
from this carrier--
your axial ligand-- is now
going to be transferred
by hydrogen atom transfer back
to p dot to form the product.
So again, it's one
electron chemistry,
and doing one
the hydrogen is transferred back
to p-- and then what do you do?
You lose one radical, and
you generate another radical.
You regenerate the
radical we started
with-- the 5-prime-deoxyadenosyl
radical on the axial ligand.
Now I have written here
hydrogen in black and in red.
Why is that true?
Because here's a methyl group.
And if you have free
complete freedom of rotation
around that carbon
carbon bond, you
can pull off either-- the methyl
hydrogens become equivalent,
so it can pull off a hydrogen
red or a hydrogen black.
OK?
Can't distinguish in the
active site of the enzyme.
So what you now generate is
the same thing we started with,
except we have a product.
But we have
5-prime-deoxyadenosyl radical
cobalt II.
Here we have
5-prime-deoxyadenosyl radical
cobalt II.
And what you do is you
re-form the carbon cobalt bond
at the end of every
turnover, and now you're
ready to start all over again.
So that's the reaction.
This 5-prime-deoxyadenosyl
radical.
This axial ligand
sitting over here
acts as a hydrogen
atom transferring agent
to remove a hydrogen
from the substrate
and to transfer it
back to the product.
OK?
I'm going to show you
how this works now
in the case of
methylmalonyl-CoA mutase.
So here's our
methylmalonyl-CoA, and we're
going to be converted
into succinyl CoA.
So this guy is migrating, and
this guy is migrating there.
That's the goal.
And so what happens here is
you cleave the carbon cobalt
bond to form cobalt II and
5-prime-deoxyadenosyl radical.
And now this
5-prime-deoxyadenosyl radical
can remove a hydrogen
atom from the substrate.
So it leaves you
with another radical.
This radical goes away.
You generate another radical.
And now this hydrogen
from the substrate
is transferred to our cofactor.
So it's the hydrogen
transferring agent.
So now the question is, how
does this weird rearrangement
reaction end?
How does this CoA migrate
from one place to another?
Again, there was no
chemical precedent
in the literature for this.
And the answer is we still
don't know the answer.
So there are two
mechanistic possibilities.
One is that you go through a
three membered ring-- cycle
propane ring intermediate.
So what you can
picture happening
is that one of the
electrons from the carbonyl
forms a bond with the unpaired
electron on this carbon.
And you generate this
cycle propane intermediate.
So you've gone from this
radical to another radical.
We haven't lost any radicals.
But now what we want to do is
we want this group to migrate.
So now what happens-- this
intermediate can collapse.
It can collapse back
to form starting
material and the
5-prime-deoxyadenosyl radical.
Or you can break this
bond, in which case
you collapse to form the direct
precursor to the product.
So it can break down
in either direction,
and the reaction's reversible.
And if it breaks down
in this direction,
you form a new radical.
This radical is distinct
from this radical.
And now what happens is that
the hydrogen that you removed
from your starting material
can be returned back
to the product.
And what you generate then is
5-prime-deoxyadenosyl radical
and cobalt II.
And now when you transfer
the hydrogen back,
you form your product
like I showed you
in the previous slide.
And now you re-form
the carbon cobalt bond
to re-form the active
form of the cofactor.
So alternatively you can
make this arrangement
happen by another mechanism
which is called a fragmentation
mechanism.
And I won't go through
the details of this,
but you can sit and look at
this for those of you who
are really interested in
sophisticated proposals
for the chemical mechanisms
of the rearrangement.
So adenosylcobalamin chemistry
was unprecedented every step
along the way.
And it's now known to be
widely used, but not so much so
in humans.
But really humans are only
a small part of the world.
We have many, many more
bacteria and archaea
than we have humans.
So this is a pretty
important transformation.
So hopefully now when
you see this again
it won't be completely magic.
But this is a challenging
reaction that most of you
haven't been exposed to before.
But hopefully some
of you get excited
about radical mediated
transformations.
Just let me close by saying--
from bioinformatic studies
in the last five
years or so, we now
know there are over
50,000 reactions that
use free radical chemistry,
yet we don't talk
about radical chemistry in 507.
So hopefully some of you
will get interested enough
in biochemistry to come
in and start figuring out
how all these radical
dependent reaction occur,
not in primary metabolism, but
in many secondary metabolic
pathways.
OK.
Thank you.